welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Andre Espeland a Japan Foundation
Center for Global Partnership
postdoctoral associate in East Asian
Studies at the Macmillan Center
professor aspirin specializes in
Japanese foreign policy and diplomacy in
East and Southeast Asia he is
particularly interested in how Japan's
normative ambitions of spreading human
rights and democracy fits within its
international relations with non
democratic and strategic partners in the
Association of Southeast Asian Nations
today we'll talk with professor Aspen
about his forthcoming paper entitled
normative power Japan settling for
Chinese democracy welcome professor
Osmond thank you
let's start with an overview of your
paper tell us about it so in this paper
I draw on the developments in Japanese
foreign policy right now with the new
Shinzo Abe big government sort of
staking out a new direction for Japanese
foreign policies we're more proactive
contribution to peace and security
specifically in the Asia Pacific region
and how Japan now seeks to utilize its
foreign aid program foreign aid that has
been a huge part of Japanese foreign
policy in a more strategic way to sort
of contribute more to Japanese national
interests and in this paper I'm
interested in understanding how such
foreign aid has been facilitating any
normative power of Japan the way Japan
could disseminate norms to other
countries in the region and I look
specifically on first the rule of law in
South in the South China Sea and how
Japan is sort of setting that
the normal legitimate behavior in that
region and I want to understand if this
normative power is them applicable to
more non-security rate related realms of
Japanese foreign policy such as human
rights and democracy okay and what led
you to write the paper what was the
catalyst so I was writing another
chapter on on the EU and Japan in the
sort of era of the rise of China and
potential modes of cooperation and I was
intrigued by the European Union sort of
not being able to extend its normative
power to other areas outside of it's
sort of geographical confines of the
European continent in its foreign aid
foreign trade relationships with for
instance Vietnam and Myanmar and so that
intrigued me to look into Japan which is
a major player in this region in terms
of foreign aid to see if Japan is able
to have a political impact on these
countries through these venues of
providing foreign aid okay and tell us
about your methodology what did you look
at
so the analytical model that I wanted to
employ for this is sort of a simplified
model where I am so in terms of sort of
measuring normative power normative
power being the ability of an actor to
set what what goes for normal in
international affairs its ability to
present its own worldview as compatible
with that of the communal am within
target state and just give us some
examples of what normative values would
be so the values that I'm looking at now
would be so rule of law the rule of
let's see in the South China Sea and
human rights democratization those those
values and norms and so the methodology
was I looked at joint policy speeches
where Japan meets a target state ahead
of
and in these venues every year they
convey hopes and wishes for the future
problems that they are incurred
encountering
and how they want to solve those and I'm
so I'm trying to trace if we can see
Japan framing these values and issues as
something that they see as important for
the target state to also comply with and
I sort of trace that through the years
in these dialogues to see if we can have
a or we if you find a reciprocation or a
sort of joint communique where both
parties agree to this and say that this
is something that we also strive for and
then I take that analytical model and I
try to place that on human rights and
democracy okay
Japan has a history of isolationism and
really showing little interest on the
world stage and in terms of playing an
active role and global affairs do you
think that is changing based on what
you're seeing I think this is something
that has been ongoing for a long time in
small incremental steps it's an
innovative inevitable change that Japan
has has had to take on by socializing
more into international community I
think it's been highlighted since the
now from 2012 and on the other
government has highlighted that even
more pushing this narrative that Japan
is in fact not a normal country is an
abnormal country it's a pacifist but a
passive pacifist country and it needs to
become an actively pacifist country and
actively pacifist country that can for
instance sell arms to other countries in
order to secure democracy that's sort of
the narrative that is being pushed more
and more by the growing political right
in Japan as opposed to the political
order sort of diminishing political left
that is actually pushing for this
as something uniquely positive for Japan
not something that is abnormal in that
sense and all of this I think needs to
be seen in against the backdrop of the
rise of China the so-called rise of
China and particularly the perception in
Japan and in in in the US for instance
and elsewhere of a China that is
increasingly assertive increasingly
aggressive and it sort of bent on
expansionism even hegemony okay and that
is something that Japan feels it needs
to address definitely and specifically
the political right sees that the only
way for Japan to be able to to to answer
to this so-called or this perceived
threat of the rise of China is to amend
the Constitution that the so called
peace Constitution article 9 where where
Japan renounces waging war as means to
settle an international dispute but the
cause of public opinion in Japan being
against a provision of the Constitution
you can see these other small steps that
Albert has been been taking for instance
for instance setting up the National
Security Council in 2013 the new
national security strategy the new
Development Corporation Charter in which
this proactive contribution to peace and
security is stipulated over and over
again and where this proactive
contribution to peace and security is
being linked to a more strategic
utilization of for and aid okay and
let's talk about that utilization of
foreign aid how is it changing and why
so in my opinion I don't think that the
actual practice of providing foreign aid
is changing that much I think that the
policies are changing and becoming more
quote/unquote honest they're becoming
more aligned with the actual practice
that has been ongoing for decades in
Japan Japanese foreign aid has always
been very much a
a national interest serving national
interest for which Japan has been
heavily criticized by the OECD the
Western traditional donors saying that
Japan should not provide concessional
loans it should bother cookies would
rather provide grant aid to countries it
should not build economic infrastructure
hard infrastructure it should build
social infrastructure but Japan has sort
of taken its own way and focused on
win-win situations where both the the
provider foreign aid and the recipient
of foreign aid wins and is that working
that has been working very well for
Japan I guess it's always a matter of
development actually leading to economic
development development aid leading to
economic development I think the jury's
still out on that but it's been very
successful for Japan in forging these
very close relationships with Southeast
Asian countries which after World War
Two obviously was not they're very
friendly position towards Japan Japan
being sort of the aggressor in this area
occupying many of the Southeast Asian
countries so it seems to be so much
strategic that Japan is trying to foster
friendships with these other countries
given the aggressive nature of China
would that be true that is definitely
the perception in Japan that the China
is is aggressive but China we also have
to remember the China is the main
competitor to Japan in building
infrastructure in Southeast Asia and
also in Africa China now has the the as
in sort of an answer to the Asia
Development Bank China two years ago
inaugurated the Asia infrastructure
investment bank which is led by China
which is all also sort of competitor to
the more Japanese led Asia Development
Bank focusing on building infrastructure
in this region so China it's both sort
of a threat strategically but it's also
a competitor economically and for that
in that sense concessional loans being
the main mode of providing foreign aid
for Japan is the
much an economic competitor in that
sense okay so what are some of your
findings in your paper so in my paper I
make the case that Japan can indeed be
called a sort of normative power
in the sense of setting the rule of law
at sea as the normal legitimate behavior
in the South China Sea and for that
Japan has successfully been using it for
an aid in terms of providing vessels
patrol vessels for these littoral States
Vietnam Philippines for instance but
it's also been developing the capacity
of coastal guards in Myanmar or in in
Malaysia and in Vietnam and in the
Philippines and so by helping these
states helping Japan to make sure that
these seas are ruled by by laws and not
might Japan in that sense have been
become a normative power how is China
though factoring into that sea space as
well so China in its own sense is a
normative power China is probably more
described for what it's not than what it
is it's not the sort of hegemony of the
European Union it's not the neoliberal
cosmopolitanism of the European Union
it's more of a do it I do we do together
look at me I develop this way you can do
the same as long as it doesn't clash
with my development and I think I think
that's what we're seeing now in in the
South China Sea we see a lot of
countries that have followed the route
of China developing in China's way and
now that they're clashing and this is
also sort of what's then feeding the
Japanese normative power how Japan can
can use China as the significant other
China is different
Japan is democratic Japan is rules
abiding Japan is by that definition
legitimate in that sense and look at
China China is the opposite it's
undemocratic it's a human rights
violator it's not abiding by the rule
law hence China is illegitimate
illegitimate so in that sense that that
boosts Japan's normative power with the
countries that are in disputes with
China okay and what do you conclude so I
think all I conclude on a country level
that Japan's foreign aid in terms of
facilitating democratization and human
rights adherence in countries that are
not specifically democratic and not
specifically interested in human rights
sections which ones such as a number of
ASEAN countries for instance allows for
instance Vietnam for instance Myanmar
Japanese aid geared specifically towards
human rights and democracy in that sense
will only be as effective or it will
only be as used to the extent that it is
actually leverage against Chinese
competition as soon as those two things
clash that will not be effective but on
a more regional level in ASEAN level
Japan by ascribing already ASEAN asked
sharing these values with with Japan as
as Prime Minister Abbott has been doing
saying ASEAN is democratic it's human
rights sharing and so on in effect what
that is doing it it's legitimizing a
sort of Chinese democracy it legitimized
or it it allows China to set the
threshold for what these countries need
to fulfill in order to be recognized as
democracies by Japan so effectively
saying that some of these countries not
being that democratic you can be part of
this in-group this democratic universal
values believing group by only
committing to a level of democracy on
par with China moving forward do you
think Japan should be doing perhaps
something different in terms of its
foreign aid I think what we're seeing
right now in the aid community is the
OECD duck the Western traditional donors
are
realizing that they are becoming
obsolete their way the traditional way
of providing aid is not competitive
anymore the emergence of China as a huge
a donor taking up on the old way that
Japan used to provide aid is now getting
Japan to also looking back at how it
used to provide a more win-win more
self-interest and that in turn is
getting the Western world to see ok this
is what we need to do if we want to stay
competitive in the foreign aid business
because that's what it is it's a
business we need to start think about
this more in terms of win-win and hence
the term for an aid is sort of
diminishing and it's increasingly
becoming development cooperation ok and
what are your next steps in turn in
terms of your research I know you're
here as a visiting scholar what have you
been working on while you're here and
really where are you planning on going
next so my first project was on this
European Union and Japan corporation in
the era of the rise of China what I want
to do in the future now is I'm going to
investigate more these sort of venues
that I think are being facilitated by
Japanese foreign aid in these countries
that are less than democratic and see if
these venues if the actual fact that
Japan has not been conditioning its
foreign aid with political requirements
if that can open up a venue of trust and
recognition that in the future might be
fruitful for a normative power or a way
to to sort of leverage against China
mm-hmm very interesting thank you for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work thank you so much for
more information about professor a
splint and his research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
[Music]